[Music]
all right buckle up stay with us for the
entire hour we will give you information
I promise and perspective that you will
not get anywhere else as the media is
once again beside themselves with false
reporting speculation and hysteria
yes Paul Manafort was found guilty after
a Northern Virginia jury found him
guilty of 8 out of 18 counts jurors
forced a mistrial and the other 10
charges after becoming deadlocked
now more evidence Muller stacking
charges he couldn't prove to scare man
afford as judge Ellis said in the
beginning into singing or composing and
he was never really ready for an actual
trial by the way Matt affort worked for
Trump a little over a hundred days and
as we've said so many times
these are decades-old bank charges tax
fraud charges zero to do with Russia
collusion zero to do with Donald Trump
or the Trump campaign now meanwhile more
breaking news today this time in New
York Michael Cohen he pled guilty to
eight federal charges including bank tax
fraud two minor campaign finance
violations far worse crimes by the way
committed by others they didn't get
charged earlier today Bret Baier raised
this very very important question let's
take a look the campaign finance
violation because the way he phrased it
that he was directed by the candidate to
do that and submitted that money to be
repaid by the Trump organization that is
a direct liability but I can already see
the battle lines being drawn here
legally because I just got an email
saying that the fact that he pleads
guilty to campaign violations does not
mean that the payments were criminal
violations this did not go to trial and
you have people like former FEC Chairman
Bradley Smith saying that payment is not
a violation which is what Rudy Giuliani
was saying in his interview earlier so
that you can already begin to see the
Trump lawyers potentially and others
making the case that this would not be a
violation
obviously the prosecutor is saying that
it is and Michael Cohen is on the hook
for it right now
and meanwhile many of the other
against Michael Kohn surround let's see
we would go from Russia to the family
taxi medallion company when once again
these charges have nothing to do with
Russian collusion from Russia collusion
to taxi cabs hello now president Trump's
attorney Rudy Giuliani released this
statement reads quote there is no
allegation of any wrongdoing against the
president in the government's charges
against mr. Cohn it is clear that as the
prosecutor noted mr. Khan's actions
reflect a pattern of Lies and dishonesty
s over a significant period of time
now while Michael cone did say today I
would argue knowing him all the years
I've known him probably forced by
prosecutors he's changed this story
about whether or not Trump knew about
the payment to stormy Daniels and Karen
McDougal back in March he claimed quote
Trump did not know that he paid Clifford
the hundred and thirty thousand dollars
a month earlier the New York Times mr.
paper of record that said the same thing
he paid the money out of his own pocket
quote without Trump's knowledge and
today we learned one more piece of
breaking news about another Muller
target and that's former national
security adviser Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn his sentencing has now
been delayed for a fourth time 2017 he
pled guilty to lying to the FBI
even though James Comey later testified
that in fact investigators did not
believe that Flynn had intentionally
lied again this guilty plea nothing to
do with Russia Russia two tax returns
two fraud two bank applications two taxi
medallions two lying to the FBI nothing
about Russia neither did the guilty plea
from the Trump campaign volunteer George
papadopolis whose wife was on last night
he pled guilty to lying to investigators
his wife mrs. papadapolis now weighing
in on his legal options and that he may
withdraw that plea without a doubt let's
be straightforward here it is wrong
there are lessons to learn from today
don't ever knowingly lie to the FBI do
not lie on a bank loan application ever
or commit bank fraud pay your taxes but
do we need robber
Muller for all of this think about this
how do you go from an investigation into
Russia collusion in the 2016 election
and this is what we have taxes from
years and years ago bank fraud
medallions lying to the FBI where's the
Russia stuff would any of these people
that we're talking about tonight have
been investigated or charged if not for
their connection to Donald Trump is it
also a lie is it also a lesson okay no
lie to the FBI pay your taxes don't lie
in a bank application don't be friends
with Donald Trump is this not now the
witch-hunt the president has been saying
an attempt to turn the screws as George
Ellis says about man afford to would be
witnesses to find dirt on one man in
other words so that they'll sing or
compose to either prosecute or impeach
the President of the United States and
if so how is that not political
selective persecution and not
prosecution now I don't care if you're
liberal or conservative we better take a
very close look at where this country is
today we did learn valuable lessons pay
your taxes don't lie on a loan
application don't lie to the FBI but
this is it Robert Muller are you proud
of this did we need you for 500 days for
this how did we go from Russia collusion
to this now today the president reacted
of Muller's ongoing witch-hunt let's
take a look at his reaction
all matter ports a good man he was with
Ronald Reagan he was with a lot of
different people over the years
I feel very sad about that
it doesn't involve me but I still feel
when you know it's a very sad thing that
happens this has nothing to do with
Russian collusion this started as
Russian collusion this has a
there's a wit shot that it's a disgrace
this has nothing to do what they started
out looking for Russians involved in our
campaign there were none it's the way it
ends up and it was not the original
mission believe me it was there was
something very much different so had
nothing to do with Russian collusion we
continue the witch-hunt
hang on I'm looking for Russians look Oh
now tonight it's not funny because these
are real people's lives these are real
families this is way beyond what this
mandate was and every American that
cares about our constitutional republic
the rule of law equal application of our
laws you better be concerned tonight now
in West Virginia the president raised an
important question where is the
collusion he raised it again let's watch
fake news of the Russian witch-hunt we
got a whole big combination where is the
collusion you know they're still looking
for collusion where is the collusion
finds of collusion we want to find the
collusion hate to say it equal justice
under the law equal application under of
our laws is dead and I will explain in a
minute calling in Manta fort are
literally prosecuted the fullest extent
of the law for bank and for tax fraud
etc let's take a look at some prominent
liberals tonight shall we that committed
similar crimes they didn't face the same
consequences
remember tax cheat Tim Geithner was the
name you haven't heard in a while
underpaid his tax instead south of the
dollars over the course of multiple
years before becoming Obama's first
Treasury secretary whoops no indictment
for him remember al Sharpton wherever
now used to be a guest on this show
works at conspiracy TV MSNBC portal II
once owed millions of dollars in back
taxes to the IRS
there's also fine $285,000 by the FEC
over an illicit political donation of
course Sharpton he's enjoying his
freedom cushy job talking about Michael
Kohn and everybody else over at NBC now
let's not forget about remember former
New York congressman Charlie Rangel
member the picture of him laying on that
beach chair
to pay taxes on tens of thousands of
dollars in real estate income Rangel
censored in the House of Representatives
he's now enjoying his retirement and
there's former Democratic Senator Tom
Daschle remember rush used to talk about
the Tom Daschle show he failed to pay
more than 128 grand in taxes and look at
this Oh even the Obama campaign in 2008
they were hit with a mere fine which at
the time was a lot 375 grand for
campaign reporting violations over two
million dollars worth Cohen is now
getting prison time somehow team Muller
missed all of those crimes wait because
there was no connection and President
Trump in today's two-tiered justice
system as a Democrat clearly you can
commit financial fraud and get away with
it by the way that's just the tip of the
iceberg if you're a Democrat and you
have subpoenaed information well first
of all you can miss handle and destroy
classified information which violates
the Espionage Act clearly you can have
top intelligence and then you can delete
subpoenaed emails not one not ten thirty
three thousand of them an acid-wash or
hard drive with bleach pit and eliminate
the evidence and then have an H smash up
your devices with hammers and get away
with it and you can even have an
exoneration written months before you're
even investigated and by the way the guy
that is doing the interview of you hates
your opponent loves you
your name is Donald Trump or you're
associated with Donald Trump your entire
life it's gonna be scoured for potential
crimes well your doors will be kicked
down late at night early in the morning
raise the screws are going to be turned
as judge Ellis said and they will ask
you to sing or compose or you'll go to
jail for crimes that other people have
committed and don't go to jail for as
Paul Manafort tonight s Michael Kohn
tonight as General Flint boy served this
country for 30 years not even the guy
that interviewed him at the FBI thought
he lied not even Comey thought he lied
not even Peter struck thought he lied as
George papadopolis I bet he regrets
volunteering for the Trump camp
just ask the White House Counsel Don
McGann oh the White House Counsel for
the president interrogate it by Muller's
team but thirty full hours Trump thinks
you know lawyers thought well what
cooperate will turn over 1.4 million
documents will cooperate with Muller and
it'll go away because we didn't do
anything wrong and the most extol pataw
evidence is in commis notes I didn't
collude I didn't conspire but if anybody
on my team did you got it you got to
hold them accountable those were in
commis notes now Motors witch-hunt is
not and has never been about Russia
collusion how did we get to taxi caps
and tax fraud and bank fraud and lies to
the FBI this is what we have been
telling you for a long time and we have
the evidence it is an attempt at a
political takedown of the man that the
deep state never wanted to be the
President of the United States I will
tell you tonight that the sovereignty of
your vote is now in question before we
get to our guests we have another
important topic to cover now for weeks
Fox news.com has been following the
heart-wrenching story out of Iowa on
July 18th a 20 year old college student
young girl all a future potential life
ahead of her Molly Tibbets went missing
today sadly her body was recovered and
now the police have arrested an illegal
immigrant they believe is responsible
for her murder
watch this a first-degree murder charge
was filed today in connection with the
disappearance of Molly Tibbets who was
last seen jogging in Brooklyn Iowa on
July 18 2018 a complaint in affidavit
names christian Vahine a-- rivera aged
24 who resides in rural policy county
and he has been charged with murder in
the first degree we have confirmed with
homeland security investigations that he
is an illegal alien and we believe his
been
in this area now for four to seven years
what happened to this young woman Molly
Tibbets is a senseless evil horrific
crime now we're believed and the charges
against an illegal immigrant
tonight we extend our deepest
condolences our prayers to her family
and her friends